isis this news just came up if you want
to pull this up with the isis story and
let's kind of go through this if you can
uh make it a little bit bigger so the
viewers can see it
uh so here we go by us rate in syria
killed top isis leader go a little lower
so we can read it in a mic if you can
give us some thoughts on this uh
president biden said on thursday that
the u.s raid in north western syria
killed top isis leader abu ibrahim
al-hashimi el horashi what he's saying
is last night at my direction u.s
military forces at my direction very
impressive u.s military forces in
northwest syria successfully undertook a
counter-terrorism operation to protect
the american people and our allies and
make the world a safer place biden said
thanks to the skill and bravery of our
armed forces we have taken off
battlefield abu ibrahim the leader of
isis all americans have returned safely
from the operations monitoring and other
groups
as well as residents of the raided
village atem atme in the rebel-held
idlib province near the border with
turkey reported multiple deaths
including civilians british
international because of nine people uh
were killed and thursday's strike
including two children and a woman wow
okay so that's the part that's gonna
british monetary
group the syrian observatory for human
rights said at least nine people were
killed in thursday's strike including
two children and a woman the syrian
civil events first responder responders
also known as the white helmet said at
least 13 people died including six
children in shelling and clashes that
followed the raid so mike former navy
seal when you see something like this
what are you thinking and what do you
know about it
well in terms of detail that i know
about it is basically zero uh with it
being this new and and me having been
out as long as i have i i have no no
connections as to any you know pertinent
details but what i will say is that
you know stuff like this takes place
pretty regularly um
from from a timing standpoint you know
it's easy to look at it and say
it's a shell game of hey things are
going bad so let me do something like
this you know there's a potential for
that no no two ways about it but i think
it's always good when uh when things
like this happen uh as it relates to
keeping
terrorist groups accountable overseas
and
uh you know keeping the pressure on them
there so that
you know they they feel the heat there
and it's harder for them to execute
things uh you know over here but i just
don't uh i i don't like the timing of it
i guess you know
it does seem a little a little
convenient because
we haven't done anything uh over there
you know his debacle or botched
abortion of a of a withdrawal from
afghanistan um
you know to me still stings and always
will for for most uh guys who have had
any involvement in the war on terror in
the last 20 years and so
uh it's hard for me not to have some
bias coming into a story like this just
because of how how badly he's fumbled uh
military
policy in the short year that he's been
at the helm if you can even call it that
by the way
tyler can you go
copy paste his name and go on google
copy paste his name abu yeah i've never
even heard of her yeah
go on google and let's read the
wikipedia because i've been going
through the wikipedia uh golden lore
yeah go the lord the main wikipedia it's
a little concerning because it's born in
october go a little lower there you go
okay good i'd make it bigger
i went somewhere let's see what born of
someone who's going down october 1976
february 3rd 2022 was an iraqi islamist
and the second leader okay so he was
second in command of the islamic state
his appointment by a shura council was
announced by the islamic state media
uh 31st of october 2019 less than a week
after the death of previous leader abu
bakr okay so he got appointed after
the us rewards the justice program while
it's offering 10 million dollars in
exchange for information leading to
uh his apprehension so does biden get
the 10 million on february 3rd 2022
he killed themselves
yeah than even by triggering an
explosive device during a
counter-terrorism rate by u.s joint
special operations come on wait so he
killed himself he did the same thing
that baghdadi did as he blew himself up
when they were coming to get him
[Music]
yeah he's not going to give you the
pride of killing him he's going to do it
himself and his family which is nice
okay so so so explain that by the way
you'd rather be you'd rather kill
yourself set off an explosive kill
yourself and your family yeah rather
than being taken out by infidels i would
explain that but uh i wish i could oh
from their mentality you spend time over
there how does that work well i mean to
me it doesn't again you know trying to
understand the the mindset and the
mentality of these guys even though you
know know your enemy and you want to
understand who you're fighting
uh is very very difficult for that
reason is that there there's such a
disparity
culturally between here and there and
religious uh you know values and things
of that nature that it makes it
i'll say for me even not being a really
a religious guy uh really really
difficult to understand what the
mentality is there i mean i i can't
understand him doing what he does to
begin with let alone
killing himself uh but it's
it's such a backwards mentality as far
as the
the way that you know hardline extremist
guys in in these networks and such the
way that they they and their families
view
uh suicide bombers is
of a very high regard well apparently
you know according to the quran if you
blow yourself up
you know in the the name of allah you
literally go to heaven you get 72
virgins
that's part of their mantra yeah i mean
i don't know uh i don't know that it
that it speaks to actual suicide in the
quran but i know that uh you know from
from the twisted
versions of uh a lot of the the networks
over there
uh and will even say
afghanistan i had uh holly mckay on my
show just a couple weeks ago who was
there during the the withdrawal
um you know in the the viewpoint and
stance that that a lot of that culture
uh you know kind of looks at
as far as the the suicide bomber
mentality is that those uh let's say
there's a 17 year old son and uh you
know he blows himself up at a checkpoint
and what have you is that that family is
now almost considered royalty like
they're paid they're they're revered
they're held at a really high standard
society
because their son blew himself yeah like
now the family is revered right and so
other
families see that and and they encourage
their their kids to do it and their kids
these are their kids these are our
sports figures our actors i mean they're
like
bomber baseball cards here before too
long i'll tell you one thing i actually
um
had an uber ride from fort lauderdale to
miami
to miami and in miami there's a 90
chance that your uber driver is going to
be of latino descent whether that's
cuban or colombian or venezuelan i mean
just that's my the makeup of the dna in
south florida this particular man was
actually palestinian
and we got into a whole long
conversation he's like so where you from
miami you're jewish yeah yeah i love
jews i'm like oh you're palestinian yes
yes you know like he got he's been in
america
for 30 plus years so thick accent and we
had a very unique conversation you know
a jew a
palestinian driver and we we actually
exchanged numbers and he
drove it was actually on new year's he
actually picked us up later point is we
had a great time and he said something
he goes you got you have to understand
one thing about these types of people
he goes i'm a muslim but i'm very
moderate he goes
they value death
more than we value life yeah and i said
whoa what
and he goes yeah they value death more
than we value life and and we just
discussed that what that meant
and i mean that kind of to your point
here mike is that
their mentality their values are totally
different than
any normal person would would have yeah
yeah absolutely and there's that's half
of it too is the other half is that you
know the the economies and societies
over there overwhelmingly so
have a kind of a feeling of despair
almost you know like that there's
unemployment rates must be just amazing
the lack of infrastructure
just there's so many negatives in in the
societies there that there's not a lot
to
uh to want to live for frankly you know
and so when you couple that with
an isolated extremist uh conditioning
from a religious standpoint and talking
about the afterlife and
you know basically brainwashing people
no different than than some aspects of
society here frankly but
but there it's it's just supercharged to
a level where it's kind of a perfect
storm of all these different elements
that contribute to
it making it very easy for them to
manipulate young
piss broke families into into sending
their their kids into
into those scenarios so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]